God all these stones man look at them
they're just massive boulders no it's a
dead end to all of this area it's
endless like dead ends you reach the
cliff face when you reach the boulder
you can't get over you try and go round
it well listen looking pretty cool
actually think there's a hint of light
through this one we've now reached what
looks like a kind of narrow dark hole of
a cave but I've seen a glimmer of light
through it and I'm thinking actually we
don't need that much to get through even
if it's that wide we reach the end of it
we'll get through it
let's make a little torch yeah we do it
from that birch bark and then go in
there use that for light and see if we
climb out through and that then access
the top part of this boulder field so
what we need that birch step is good let
me going cut that stick I was like oh we
won't go in there we're going in there
and there's like a little speck of light
have you ever seen descent
I really hope that's not happening today
chop you that if you never see me again
you know where Norway but bear crawls
help then we need the Chagga okay
where's that little Flint you had here
so this is old school
that's Flint and then this is like what
I call a nap and they used to just carry
this around just go see it but it's hard
you're gonna so technically I was wrong
the Norwegian ship thing was not a
moustache protector I'm okay with
knitting nuts so they hold the metal bit
down yeah and then just flicked me Flint
alone there you go we got we got it we
got it that thang there you go
I've never started a fire as easy as
this I mean it took one tiny little
spark barely an ember and it just like
ignited and burning slowly into the
stuff called Chagga that okay you ready
[Music]